- Ah c’est magnifique !
- C’est fou comme c’est bien conservé.
Tu te rends compte, ça a presque mille ans.
Mille ans ? Quand on y pense, on se demande ce qu’il va rester de notre XXIe siècle à nous.
Qu’est-ce qui va rester dans milles ans ?
C’est vrai ça.
La poutre, c’est le ciment du Moyen- ge et de la civilisation…
Que restera-t-il de nous ?
Voilà une question qui évoque plus souvent une réflexion spirituelle qu’une interrogation archéologique,
et à laquelle j’ai envie de répondre par une autre question :
Quand ça ?
Admettons que, dans le futur, il y ait encore quelqu’un ou quelque chose
pour s’intéresser au passé de la civilisation humaine...
eh bien, je vous propose d’avancer dans le temps pour imaginer quels vestiges historiques, archéologiques et géologiques
seront encore présents pour décrire notre XXIe siècle.
Avançons directement de quelques siècles.
À l’aube du 4e millénaire, les archives historiques de notre époque deviendront une denrée rare et précieuse pour reconstruire la vie au XXIe siècle.
Première idée d’archive : le papier.
En effet, certain papyrus se sont conservés sur plus de 4500 ans,
et les premiers papiers “modernes” faits à base de fibres végétales hachées ont travers plus de 2000 ans.
Mais malheureusement, le papier du 21ème siècle est victime de son propre procédé de fabrication.
L’acidité des colles présentes dans les pâtes de bois utilisées depuis 1870,
le dégrade en quelques dizaines d’années.
Malgré une amélioration de la qualité du papier dans les années 80,
l’utilisation croissante du papier recyclé n’arrange pas les choses.
Donc, dans quelques centaines d’années, dans les vestiges des bibliothèques,
on ne trouvera probablement que quelques miettes de nos bouquins et de nos photos.
Mais heureusement, depuis les années 1990, tout est méthodiquement numérisé !
Les archéologues du futur se baseront donc sur des archives numériques !
Ou pas.
Le numérique est confronté au même problème de conservation du support.
Les disques optiques (CD ou DVD) sont composés de différents dépots chimiques,
qui sont extrêmement sensibles aux changements de température, à la lumière, aux rayures, et à d’autres agressions du temps encore mal comprises.
Selon le Laboratoire national d'essais leur durée de vie ne dépasse pas 15 ans en moyenne...
Les disques durs, ont eux aussi une durée de vie de quelques années seulement, et les data centers ne seront pas éternels…
Ainsi, aussi surprenant que ça puisse paraître,
le CERN qui gère aujourd’hui le plus grand volume de données au monde en physique des particules
a choisi d’archiver sur des bandes magnétiques.
À ce jour, les bandes sont la technologie la moins coûteuse pour un archivage à cette échelle, mais aussi la plus fiable
car on connaît exactement les conditions de conservations idéales,
et si elles sont respectées, on peut envisager de les garder plusieurs centaines d’années.
Et pour les supports numériques, même s’ils sont de multiples fois copiés pour perdurer dans le temps,
s’ils sont conservés avec précaution,
rien ne garantit que des archéologues du futur auront une technologie capable de décoder nos données.
On a déjà du mal à ouvrir des fichiers enregistrés sur 2 versions différentes de Windows...
Finalement, c’est ce qui est paradoxal.
Les supports les plus récents ne semblent pas être les plus adaptés à la conservation d’archives sur le très long terme.
Au contraire même, les supports numériques sont les plus difficiles à restaurer et les effets du temps effacent des pans entiers de données.
Un DVD rayé devient illisible.
Un disque dur qui a crashé, entraine la perte de toutes les données,
alors qu’un papier déchiré laisse visible une partie de son contenu,
une plaque de verre photographique, même brisée, aux couleurs passées, laisse entrevoir la scène qu’elle a immortalisé.
- Et donc c’est pour ça que c’est paradoxal. Le numérique, il ne pourra pas se conserver.
Oui mais en même temps, le numérique, ça permet de stocker des quantités phénoménales de données.
Y a des bibliothèques entières qui peuvent tenir sur un disque dur.
C’est ça qui manque aux archéologues.
Oui mais du coup, il faut inventer de nouveaux supports.
Justement, les chercheurs en ce moment, ils sont en train d’imaginer de nouveaux trucs,
comme par exemple, stocker dans des brins d’ADN.
Et ils ont réussi en 2016, je crois,
à stocker des données d’un manuscrit dans un brin d’ADN qu’ils ont mis dans une petite capsule de silice,
et ils l’ont fait vieillir en accéléré, jusqu’à 2000 ans.
Et là, ils ont réussi à lire ce qu’il y avait dans l’ADN.
- Donc c’est peut-être comme ça que l’on pourra transmettre nos données.
- Wahou !
Donc, les poutres de 12, mais de 12 principalement, c’est vraiment…
Avançons encore un peu dans le temps.
Disons, quelques millénaires.
Une fois ces archives disparues, quand tous ces technofossiles seront devenus inutilisables et indéchiffrables,
les explorateurs du futur devront se pencher sur un autre type de vestige.
Comme au XXIe siècle, dans quelques millénaires, les matériaux les plus résistants au temps resteront la pierre, la céramique, le verre,
en gros, tout ce qui est issu des roches.
Mais le matériau qu’ils trouveront en masse, et qui leur apportera sûrement le plus d’info,
c’est le plastique.
On dit souvent que les archéologues fouillent les poubelles du passé, et à ce compte là, les archéologues spécialistes du XXIe siècle seront très très chanceux.
La production industrielle de plastique a commencé dans les années 50.
Les chercheurs  Geyer, Jambeck et Lavender Law ont estimé à 8,3 milliards de tonnes
la masse totale de plastique sur la planète en 2015,
et 6,3 milliards de tonnes se sont retrouvées dans nos poubelles.
Seulement 12% de ces déchets ont été incinérés et 9% recyclés.
C’est donc la totalité de la planète qui est recouverte de plastiques.
On trouve des microplastiques dans les lacs de montagnes, des emballages dans le ventre des baleines, des billes dans notre dentifrice.
Les plastiques biodégradables eux existent depuis la fin des années 80.
On a commencé à les commercialiser avec la promesse implicite qu’ils disparaîtraient une fois jetés,
mais les choses ne se sont pas tout à fait déroulées comme prévu.
Ils ne donnent pas les résultats escomptés ni dans le jardin, ni dans l’eau, ni dans un site d’enfouissement.
Pour se décomposer, il leur faut les 55°C des centres de compostage industriel.
Donc, ils ne sont donc pas tout à fait prêts à remplacer le bon vieux plastique.
Avec une durée de vie d’au moins 1000 ou 1500 ans selon sa composition, sa taille et les conditions de dégradation,
on peut imaginer que les archéologues du turfu seraient avant tout des spécialistes du déchet plastique.
Et ils devraient aussi retrouver des quantités massives d’os de poulets.
Oui oui, avec plus de 65 milliards de poulets consommés chaque année, c’est la viande la plus mangée au monde.
Et nous en avons fait l’espèce vertébrée la plus répandue sur Terre.
En s’accumulant, les os de nos amis à 2 pattes forment progressivement un des principaux témoignages biologiques de notre époque.
Mais du coup, tu imagines, si ça se trouve, les explorateurs du futur, ils vont penser qu’on était juste
des animaux domestiques d’une civilisation de poulets hyper développée.
Nan mais en fait, c’est vrai, s’ils n’ont pas de quoi interpréter les vestiges, c’est super compliqué.
C’est toujours un problème d’interprétation.
C’est exactement le problème qui se pose avec Onkalo.
Onkalo, c’est un immense complexe souterrain qui est en cours de construction en Finlande,
et dont le but est de stocker les déchets nucléaires du pays pendant les 100.000 ans à venir.
Et 100.000 ans, c’est quelque chose d’incomparable dans l’histoire de l’humanité
puisque les plus vieilles constructions humaines qu’on connaisse, elles ont aux alentours de 7000 ans.
Ce projet nous pousse à penser au-delà de l’humanité elle-même.
Et actuellement, il y a des gens qui se demandent comment expliquer à nos très lointains descendants
qu’il ne faut pas entrer dans le site parce qu’il est toxique,
étant donné que toutes nos langues et tous nos signes seront obsolètes.
Il y a une autre école qui pense qu’il ne faut pas prévenir puisque, bah nous, en général,
quand on s’est retrouvé devant des inscriptions antiques qui nous demandaient de ne pas ouvrir un sarcophage par exemple,
bah la première chose qu’on faisait, c’était de l’ouvrir.
- Ouais.
Avançons encore de 55 millions d’années.
Cette fois, nous sommes à l’échelle des temps géologiques, et la mémoire de la civilisation humaine depuis bien longtemps disparue.
Est-ce qu’une forme de vie curieuse et étrangement douée pour la géologie serait capable de détecter le passage des humains sur Terre ?
Adam Frank et Gavin Schmidt se sont posés la question dans un article publié en 2018 intitulé
« L’hypothèse silurienne : serait-il possible de détecter une civilisation industrielle dans les strates géologiques ? ».
Oui les chercheurs aussi regardent Docteur Who.
Leur conclusion, c’est que 55 millions d’années c’est vraiment très très long.
... Oui.
Plus de ruines enfouies dans la terre, peu de fossiles, et même le plastique, auraient eu le temps de se dégrader,
même s’il pourrait peut être en rester au niveau microscopique.
Mais 3 indices de la civilisation humaine seraient inscrits dans la chimie du sol.
les engrais, oui, notre usage à très grande échelle laisserait une empreinte d’azote visible dans les sédiments pendant des dizaines de millions d’années.
Les métaux rares, leur utilisation dans nos appareils électroniques devrait en laisser une forte concentration dans une strate géologique bien précise.
Et les carburants fossiles, tout ce que nous brûlons depuis un siècle consiste en du carbone
provenant de créatures mortes tout au long des ères géologiques précédentes.
La créature géologue du futur pourrait donc s’étonner de découvrir que des réserves de carbone accumulées pendant aussi longtemps ont été soudainement vidées.
Et le tout, très bizarrement accompagné d’une hausse de la température.
Et si je vous parle de 55 millions d’années c’est parce que justement, sur Terre, entre le paléocène et l’éocène,
il y a 56 millions d’années, la température a augmenté, jusqu’à 8 degrés de plus qu’aujourd’hui.
Sauf que cette hausse, accompagnée d’une accumulation de carbone dans l’atmosphère, s’est étalée sur des centaines de milliers d’années,
et c’est ce qui la rend visible dans les strates géologiques.
Notre mauvaise gestion des ressources de la planète pourrait laisser une empreinte géologique, mais cette transformation a lieu à un rythme si rapide
qu’elle ne serait peut être pas détectable dans les couches géologiques.
Et il est dont très peu probable qu’un géologue du turfu, introduise “l’anthropocène” comme nouvelle époque géologique au même titre que les époques en “-cène” que nous connaissons
et qui elles, ont une durée moyenne de 12 millions d’années.
Cette idée médiatique et très anthropocentrée, n’a pas vraiment de sens géologique.
Par contre, les géologues de tous temps ont identifié des crises qui séparent les ères géologiques.
Comme la crise Crétacé-Tertiaire il y a 60 millions d’années, qui a décimé la plupart des dinosaures.
Ces crises sont géologiquement très brèves (quelques années pour la crise Crétacé Tertiaire,
à quelques centaines de milliers d'années pour les autres) et synonymes d’extinction massives de population animales.
Alors la crise anthropique, on en parle ?
Donc à l’échelle des temps géologique, bah notre passage, il laissera presque rien.
Et si on veut vraiment laisser quelque chose du XXIe siècle,
je pense qu’il faudra qu’on trouve un moyen de transmettre nos objets sur le long terme.
Comme une capsule temporelle.
Merci d’avoir regardé cet épisode du Vortex qui parle de géologie.
Et je vous dis, abonnez-vous, rejoignez le Discord et, à la prochaine.
La colonne, c’est la poutre inversée. C’est le lieu de culte de poutre, parce que ça se dirige vers le ciel. C’est l’élévation, tu vois ?
Une poutre dressée.
C’est une poutre dressée.
Mais ça, c’est une colonne comme-ça sans rien au-dessus, c’est lieu de culte de la poutre.
C’est là que tu viens déposer tes offrandes au Grand Poutreur.